cyberpunk is finally here on next-gen
consoles so of course we have to do a
another comparison with what is now the
proper ps5 version versus the ps4 pro
version of the game for the pro version
we captured right before the update and
for the ps5 version with the performance
mode where the game runs at 60 frames a
second at dynamic 4k however even
without the enhancements of ray traced
shadows the difference in visual quality
between the ps4 pro and ps5 version is
pretty stark in some places you'll
notice a lot of improvements to lighting
textures and even object detail if you
want to know more about our overall
thoughts on the next gen version of
cyberpunk check out the conversation
that me and lucy james had about the
update and as always if you enjoyed this
video why not give us a like and hit the
sub button if you haven't already we
really appreciate it and with that
enjoy the video
electric coupling module
you said it was nothing serious when i
came in you said you were sure
that's fine step aside what
got any idea what to do
hmm
i'm gonna bypass the coupling and rig a
hot wire
compressor run on and on it could seize
up
okay
let's see what happens
it's like i was telling you
not shabby at all questions how long
it'll last you
it'll get me to night city i figure
something else out there
right
i'll just fix it and go i have no reason
to linger
no you sure [ __ ] don't
nothing boils my blood like a [ __ ]
stray
where'd your clan pitch camp
hello
come in
come in
ah raised to finally
willie mccoy it's good to hear your
voice
fee
wish i could say the same
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
us
yeah partner
we'll go half season
any decent fixer will find a loaded gonk
interested in a rare gem like this
it's kind of a shame though
i always wanted a pet
got the name manny all thought out
hey by the way
you uh got any plans for what you'll be
doing in night city
okay partner time to grab the lizard and
scurry out of here
hello there
night city
[Applause]
stanley here with you and we got another
day ahead of us in this city of dreams
oh i love this town love it like you
might love a mother who popped you out
on the steps of an orphanage once and
now stops you to ask if you got a smoke
fur
every new day here means a hundred new
arrivals but only half these guns will
survive a year
you ac's legends know where you'll find
most of them
the graveyard
matters not where you're from that is
not where you start
what matters here is the walk you walk
in night city
the city of dreams
not just any other city
morgan blackhand
adam smasher
legends are born here
let's grab a tight bite what do you say
jackie they're locking down watsons
[ __ ] drive
jackie come on [ __ ]
can't keep her steady
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
ain't for the driver
scratched your baby up pretty bad
like yesterday
took you long enough
worked up an appetite just waiting
sit down let me finish this
and we can drop in on senor vektor
[Music]
but it just so happens
i think i might have bagged us a sweet
ass j.o.b
go on
i mean
maybe it's not as big as that but
just that he's fronted by a little known
someone named dexter deshawn man
totally the top fixer in knight [ __ ]
city
fat ass black jesus of the afterlife
yo mr v a pleasure
dexter deshawn in the flesh
ample indeed
let's roll
mind if i ask you something right off
the bangle
would you rather live in pieces mr
nobody die ripe old and smelling
slightly of urine or go down for all
times in a blaze of glory smelling near
like posies without seeing your 30th
then there's the other thing gotta meet
the client who put the job on the table
evelyn parker
you
oh what's dex gonna do
right around in his limo chat chicks up
on the hollow
parker wants to meet someone on the crew
dex gave me the nod
he must know what he's doing
so
how you want to play this bell strummer
parker was first
i say we knock on maelstrom's door first
pound actually
in that case i'll hit the all foods put
my nose to the ground
sniff around